there that's what happened to Kanye I
mean when he got older he found out his
um his mother that he like adored yeah
wasn't letting him see his father and
like left
um where his father was and moved to
Chicago yeah
um and I honestly think that should be a
crime well I think that should be occur
if you if you keep your your baby father
from your kids I think that you should
be charged with something because you're
putting your kid at everything yeah yeah
you're you're putting your kid at every
statistical
disadvantage for what is that is that a
hyperbole or is that like an actual fact
Paul well I'll tell you the facts ninety
percent of single parent homes are
headed by women ninety percent right 63
of Youth suicides are from single mother
homes ninety percent of homelessness and
runaway children are from single mother
homes 71 of high school dropouts are
from single mother home 70 of youths in
operated institutions are from single
mobile homes 80 of all youths in prison
are from single mother homes 85 percent
of children who show behavioral
disorders are from single mother homes
80 of grapists with anger problems are
from where single mother homes so like
spell says you're putting your child at
every every statistical disadvantage
when you choose to just be a
quote-unquote single mother and I think
if you leave the Dad should get the kids
if you choose to leave I'm sorry you
don't get rewarded and then you know
it's the worst thing when they'll be
like oh I have to watch the kids okay
give them to him then
um like the girls will always say oh I
had to watch the kids I'm like what do
you mean you get to spend time with your
children that's not a that's a good
thing give them to him then no but I
swear the system is like if the if the
male has the child for a certain amount
of time then it's co-parenting so they
don't get any money well I can have a
little bit anecdotal story here right
um when I broke up with my son's mom I
didn't realize that when you co-parent
in this country when you actually
co-parent meaning you do 50 50 nobody
owes each other any money yeah I didn't
know that so I was given like money each
month and all this kind of stuff did she
know that I please assume she did I
don't know I don't know and then then I
read it somebody said it to me and I
read it and I was like oh oh snap what
am I giving you money for I'm like yeah
it's true I don't have to give you no
dough and that's when the problem
started
they've been told this from time like yo
make sure you
um don't don't allow him too many days
you get me because yeah yeah because
they're yeah you're paid you're paid
you're paid you're given more money if
you don't let him see the kids so like
women are incentivized to not let you
see the children yeah and it's not like
people always get on me and say like I'm
harsh on women I'm like I I think men if
they were paid to do bad things they
would also do bad things but women are
paid for bad decisions of course
there was a um
a couple from America they're on Love
and Hip Hop can't remember which one but
Safari I think with Safari and his now
Erica Erica yep there you go
um they got divorced and I don't know
the ramification of the divorce nothing
but then she got a word of how much she
was receiving in child support and it
was around like was it I think it was
like six thousand four thousand four
thousand and she was upset about that
like
what is a child that's four thousand
dollars a child can live on that until
they're
eighteen four thousand dollars whatever
every month every month every month like
I'm like okay thanks four thousand
dollars cool but she was upset that it
was so little little and she was like I
went through this I went through that
just to get four thousand dollars I'm
like you could get nothing like four
thousand dollars is a lot what do you do
you need it for you or do you need for
your child if you just need it for your
child you're straight because you
apparently have what you need for you
and she'd go around saying oh he's a
deadbeat he doesn't give enough money
but do you why did you stop the story
there why didn't you continue it so well
I found out that she she co-parents with
him oh see I didn't know that yeah big
co-parent oh really and he still gives
her money
I don't think that's a law in the states
though the same is here I think no no
I'm saying he drops her pee like wait so
no because that was a court decision but
he said on his Instagram that my
co-parent yeah but I don't I don't think
it matters in the states like if you
co-parent or not you still have to pay
child support if they take you to
remember what I'm saying if I if I have
the child for free free days of the week
that four thousand you're still thinking
the 4000 is like okay get me for the
whole month you know it's just for free
days in the week that you got him yeah
well four days like half the month yeah
it's like half the month like 15 days
yeah it's like how how much money does a
parent need I mean I know that when my
son's with me half the week I'm the one
clothing him I'm the one feeding him
he's he's using electricity that I pay
for you know what that I pay for it it's
one of those things that men have kind
of been conditioned to think oh you're
supposed to give the mother of your
child money each month because she would
be the one struggling and it's like well
I might be struggling too like I've got
I've got the child here too you know
what I mean like he's giving me money
and women want equality until it doesn't
benefit until it doesn't benefit yeah
and that's that's the thing like we want
it to be equal be equal what the [ __ ]
like you have a job to get baby mama
should get a job are we addressing the
elephant in the room which is what huh
um listen I'll light up the internet
please okay let me let me address it let
me address a little bit of it you get me
because it seems like Pearl don't want
to address it I'll address it
first and foremost yeah if you want to
clip this you can clip this and send
this wherever you want to send this bro
just pearly things yeah just pearly
things is a network yeah so when you
when you tag just pearly things just
know you're coming for everyone on the
on the show with all our views combined
yeah
so I'll start with that secondly Abba
and preach here these guys oh my God no
like should I should like all right this
is left the field by going okay so first
of all yeah this is the elephant yeah
this is the elephant in the room because
you know what they're doing they've gone
around here and my man has basically
said you're misogynistic
bro I met a man called a woman
misogynistic because she because she's
because you know what I'm trying to say
and uh when they say you gotta say
divorce but I keep going bro no no no no
no no no we're going we're gonna get
them we're gonna get them listen you've
sat down and you've ate off just pearly
things by tagging us yeah and your
production is not our production our
production is Big out here you get me we
do we have guests coming in we have big
sets Ox blessing you know what I'm
saying we have stuff we go we go we go
outside we put people in in black
people's pockets yeah so for two guys
from wherever you look from because it's
not from Haiti because if it was from
Haiti you would have spoke about it yeah
you would have spoke about what's going
on in Haiti but don't sound like that
sound like you're from upside so listen
let me say turn into YouTube guys here
do not mention just pearly things again
yeah otherwise it'll be more smoke bro
I've got bear smoke for you not bro both
of you look I got smoke for Abba and
Peach bro
preach a little bit less but I got smoke
for you bro po how old are you
uh I just turned 26. all right Paul just
turned 26. you little big man yeah as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible